[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
877 personnes et puis soixante deux
entités au total tout cela est très bien
on a aussi vu ces images de yachts de
propriété immobilisé çà et là en france
en allemagne et à l'image le yacht de
romane abramovitch l'oligarque proche de
poutine à la tête du club de chelsea on
en a parlé des ukrainiens ont essayé de
l'empêcher d'accoster en turquie en vain
vous le voyez dans la panique de la
fuite les ukrainiennes n'oublie jamais
leurs animaux de compagnie certains
chats voyages groupés des maîtres
portent leurs animaux malades même
encombrant qui est allongé les mines
antichars je ne condamne pas du tout
ceux qui ont une villa à miami ou sur la
côte d'azur tant qu'ils ne peuvent pas
se passer de foie gras ou d'huîtres le
problème c'est que beaucoup de ces
personnes ne sont mentalement asie signe
pas avec notre peuple pas du côté de la
russie plus d'un million d'internautes
suivent le quotidien de stepan un félin
de kharkiv devenu symbole du sort des
animaux dans ce conflit le chat âgé de
13 ans était déjà célèbre pour cette
photo postée l'année dernière n'est pas
forcément solidaire du gouvernement
ukrainien ça c'est un trait à quelque
chose qui est plus compliqué après lui
on est contre l'impérialisme russe et
contre l'agression effectivement
militaire de poutine mais c'est pas pour
autant qu'on sans faire de jeu de mots
qu'on est du côté des autres
impérialisme aujourd'hui stéphane et sa
maîtresse sont en sécurité en france à
nice spontanément ils se sont rassemblés
devant la préfecture d'ajaccio ce matin
ces lycéens ces étudiants rendre un
ultime hommage à yvan colonna un rapport
a été demandé des conséquences en seront
tirés parce que on ne peut pas laisser
dans nos prisons de tels gestes être
commis mais je pense que dans ce
contexte le plus important est en effet
clair le calme se maintiennent qu'un
détenu français soit agressé dans une
prison française par l'un de ses
codétenus qui est un multirécidiviste
qui étaient condamnées pour djihadisme
qui est donc un islamiste dangereux
forcené qui est auxiliaires de
l'administration c'est à dire qui
bénéficie à la fois d'une rémunération
et d'une délégation de mission de
service public pose un véritable
problème je suis lancinant
notre système judiciaire ne marche plus
ne fonctionne plus et ce qui est
étonnant c'est que monsieur dupont
moretti soit toujours en place
aujourd'hui ça pose une autre question
encore derrière que vont faire que
l'état nous dit il sur ces 60 à 80
détenus djihadistes qui vont bientôt
sortir de prison d'ici le premier tour
on peut rejoindre le suma cran et ce
deuxième tour sera très ouvert il y à un
risque d'abstention donc nous mobilisons
évidemment nos électeurs ceux qui
veulent un véritable changement jusqu'au
dernier moment attention emmanuel macron
êtes en train de vous laisser une dette
abyssale financière l'addition de tous
les chèques qui sont faits c'est après
l'élection je ne pense pas qu'elle
faisait beau ce sera le prochain
président de la république
voilà
je ne pense pas qu'il sera au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle
je ne pense pas qu'il aurait dû même
être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
allez vous choisir marine le pen comme
premier ministre je n'ai pas encore fait
mon choix de premier ministre dont on
verra il faudra d'abord que marine le
pen me soutiennent mais je ne doute pas
qu'elle le fera roncevaux toi quand il
était chroniqueur au 10è baisse et ce
dès qu'un journaliste pardon de
l'expression
mais là aujourd'hui
il intervient comme un responsable
politique d'ailleurs doté d'aucun mandat
et c'est là que le mal se produit un
soutien de poids mais qui s'est fait
attendre françois hollande cette affiche
est à ses côtés a prononcé ces mots je
suis là parce que je suis socialiste je
suis là parce que je suis fidèle et
loyal